completely unrelated but right after the
fccj thing we did
yeah i got two emails from i don't even
know if they're students or teachers or
what from my
high school right uh in welsh uh just
from saying my one of the teachers
misses me or something
what and i was like what how does the
teacher remember you
oh well i actually i mean i i they
remember it's a small school and also
i uh my i think we've had like um
so my brother and my little brother went
there so three generations of ours right
right and i've also i did talks
there you did tomorrow you all like went
back oh yeah yeah yeah
there which was uh terrible because i
didn't prepare at all i just went there
and i was like what do you mean
i don't know are you youtubers
is i'm a youtuber and every kid is like
tell me more no tell me about it
i'm immediately interested actually now
i have a frame of reference so i've done
two talks now i've done one talk at my
high school for six form students which
are like 17
yeah 18. um and i've done a talk at my
mum's primary school
for like 10 year olds it was very very
different experience yeah and i way
way way way enjoyed talking for the 10
year olds way more than i did the 17
year old
because 17 year olds they're at their
age where they're way too shy
about everything yeah yeah yeah and
they're like starting to get
self-conscious
they hate life yeah i mean i did i mean
everyone everyone remembers that age
and so even though i thought yeah i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a youtuber this is like a cool
ass job
yeah i'd be [ __ ] i'd be like yeah
this is sick when i helped my life all
right so he's got any questions
[ __ ] no one had a question i'm like
wait what's going on
am i not cool am i not cool is this not
epic
it's like are you not being entertained
right
the teacher felt bad for me and he was
like i have a question
oh my oh [ __ ] oh god you got a pewdiepie
yeah
you got the you got the pity question
yeah yeah but then i think they started
asking some questions it was all right
it was just terrible and i had to talk
in welsh as well and i'm i i could
talking whilst but i'm not as like
uh able to express myself as much and
watch how do you say youtuber and walsh
just youtuber oh youtuber so it's boring
same with thai
fair enough on the youtube youtube
channel a slightly different accent
um yeah do we need youtube just that's
it but um
yeah and uh it was all right it was just
fine i i should have prepared more but i
also
didn't know what to talk about i was
like just just ask me [ __ ] i guess the
ten-year-olds would have been better
right because they were more curious bro
they were great they were like [ __ ]
loving it they were because i also
was doing over zoom right and i had my
oh you did it zoom
yeah yeah because uh it was i did this
like three weeks ago
oh [ __ ] you didn't tell me about it you
didn't tell me about this i'm saving for
trash taste
oh
i set up my streaming stuff as a virtual
webcam
so basically i had like my stream set up
up to the zoom
and what i was doing was yeah that's
just my phillips lights back there you
know
you're like what do you think twitch i
mean
like all the zooms and the wide angles
and i was like [ __ ] around with that
and doing all the sound effects and
doing
like the like memes sounds and stuff
while i was doing the presentation for
them and like answering their questions
you like these mediums kids
yeah i was literally doing like live
video editing
and these [ __ ] kids are losing it bro
it was so funny
private live stream you just did a
private twitch stream yeah basically
yeah it was so fun these kids loved it
bro they were like i bet
they were like like every time i did
like the [ __ ] wide camera angle they
started like pissing themselves laughing
it was so fun and uh
and they also all watched anime oh wow
which is like great
yeah i remember you saying in the ccj
interview that you're like what's your
favorite anime you said attack on titan
yeah i assume you just said that because
you were just like what's a popular
anime yeah yeah yeah
yeah so these kids are 10 years old they
should not be watching attack on titan
yeah
they should not be watching should've
said jojo and see if
how far the net has been casted so i
said attack on titan
and these kids are like yes they're like
who's your favorite character i was like
captain levi and they're like yes
and i was like what the [ __ ] what's
going on what's your favorite sound
effect then i started playing with them
and stuff yeah
they were like i was surprised because
normally the one question you get from
kids is like how much do you make none
of them ask that i was like wow yeah
nice kids very respectful
yeah because like at that age right like
youtube is still like kind of in the
dreamscape
right it's not until you you hit high
school where you're like so is it worth
not going to you do 10 year olds care
about how much money people make
i don't i don't i think some dude i
never cared at 10 years old i don't know
it depends on the kid but they were
really nice they asked you know they
were like oh
what what age do you recommend starting
youtube that's a tough question
because at once at one point i would
recommend stay as far away from the
internet as possible
as long as you can but also on the other
hand you know getting experience editing
is never a bad thing like getting good
at video editing from like age 12
it's just great experience i mean just
for life in general like being able to
make videos is a super
useful like and very handy technique
that will come in useful
i guarantee in your life at some point
you will want to make it even in a
corporate job
yeah yeah yeah you will want to make a
video at some point and being able to
make a video and not [ __ ] yourself
opening software
is very useful um you know i was saying
you know it's
just being able to learn something is
great yeah it's great these kids are
really good
i was like i sort of like i felt like i
was like kind of proud i was like this
kid's good good
kids so they're asking the right
questions
you got a good set there man they were
like did you like school and i was like
of course i did only when my mom told me
to
my mom was in the room now okay i was
like yeah of course and they were like
oh you know
they were like oh uh did you like school
and i was like of course i did that's
what i told mrs [ __ ] but secretly no i
didn't um
so so this thing was it a zoom call
where or with
where is was it like a virtual classroom
or were they in a physical classroom
they were in a physical classroom
like a big screen okay and i could see
them and then
at one point i tried to show them my
audio setup thing
yeah and it unplugged and crashed my
whole pc
and i was like texting my mom i was like
mom i'm sorry give me five minutes gotta
reboot my whole pc
was it pretty bad but it was good fun
they were really cute i want to do that
i want to do that
that's really fun
hey heights primary school give me an
email hey bladgington milk come on come
on
come on i'm right there i'm right there
man i just
tell my mom i was like sure because my
mom really wanted to i don't know maybe
she wanted the flex i don't know
i don't know my mom wanted because they
all knew i was a youtuber but my mom
didn't want to
tell them who i was because my stuff is
not appropriate for 10 year olds yeah
yeah yeah
i was like fair enough i mean especially
trash chases yeah yeah that's not sure
never mind besides i take that back
maybe it's not a good idea for the kids
to be exposed to mine don't want to talk
about it i have to know your youtube
channel
maybe the sixth graders can watch but
anyone below that probably not like
justin mill show them the hentai yeah
so he's like [ __ ] i i went to a porn
studio
he's my favorite porno yeah perfect
i'll send you the patreon version it's
all right
yeah it was fine i mean the it was way
more fun in the high school because the
high school i just stood there yeah i
was like what do you want to know
no lie oh nothing like you're all boring
we know what you do